und wie ist die militärische Lage
einzuschätzen darüber spreche ich jetzt
mit Christian Mölling von der Deutschen
Gesellschaft für auswärtige Politik
guten Abend nach Berlin hallo guten
Abend es heißt immer Russland könne
diesen Krieg nicht gewinnen ist das so
oder machen sich die Ukraine und der
Westen da was vor
nein wir sehen ja seit zehn Monaten das
Russland immer weniger militärische
Optionen hat das beschießen der zivilen
Infrastruktur ist ja eigentlich ein
Ausdruck davon dass man keine
militärischen Optionen tatsächlich mehr
hat um an der Front und auf den auf dem
Gefechtsfeld nach vorne zu kommen so
dass man sich andere Mittel sucht um
hier Erfolge zu erzielen Erfolge die
auch wichtig sind zu Hause für Putin
weil er eben militärisch nichts
vorzuweisen hat in dieser Nacht hat es
wieder heftige Angriffe gegeben offenbar
mit iranischen Drohnen da zeichnet sich
so eine Art militärpartnerschaft ab
zwischen den Regimen in Moskau und
Teheran wie gefährlich ist das
natürlich schafft Moskau es jetzt
erstmal durch die Lieferung aus dem Iran
die die Angriffe auf die zivile
Infrastruktur vorzusetzen das ändert
aber an der Lage im Gefechtsfeld eben
selber nichts da sieht es so aus als ob
die Ukraine einfach durch die Lieferung
aus dem Westen für das wintermaterial im
Vorteil ist und dazu kommt auch dass
insbesondere die USA jetzt ihre
Produktion an Munition hochfahren und
damit ab 2023 verstärkt die Ukraine
unterstützen können wir sehen insgesamt
dass ich zwar die Lage durch den Winter
verändert das aber der Krieg deswegen
nicht aufhören wird
zurzeit trifft Putin den weißrussischen
Diktator Lukaschenko das Militär von
Belarus sei einsatzbereit hieß es heute
rechnen Sie mit einem Angriff von
Belarus auf die Ukraine das ist zurzeit
noch relativ unwahrscheinlich auch
deswegen weil die Belle russischen
Streitkräfte auf der einen Seite kein
Interesse haben oder lukaschenker kein
Interesse hat in diesem Krieg
hineingezogen zu werden sie auch
schlecht ausgerüstet sind und ähm
schlecht ausgebildet sind von daher ist
das zurzeit möglicherweise eher eine Art
von Propaganda Maschine die hier anläuft
von daher geht es glaube ich eher darum
darauf zu gucken was im Osten und im
Süden der Ukraine abläuft
nichtsdestotrotz gilt wir haben viele
Chancen vertan in den letzten Monaten
als Westen wir hätten die Ukraine schon
längst soweit bringen können dass sie
diesen Krieg gewinnt die Frage ist und
die Hoffnung ist dass Deutschland und
Europa in 2023 mehr tun werden
Kriege Enden ja mit Sieger und besiegten
oder eben am Verhandlungstisch auf
beides deutet gerade nichts hin wie lang
wird dieser Krieg noch dauern also der
Verhandlungstisch und das Gefechtsfeld
schließen sich nicht aus sondern im
Gegenteil sie begegnen sich gegenseitig
diese Bedingungen sich gegenseitig das
heißt also erst wenn auf dem
Gefechtsfeld stillstand ist ist es
überhaupt möglich zu verhandeln und ist
auf der politischen Ebene so dass
eigentlich die Verhandlungsmasse durch
Putin immer weiter verringert worden ist
er besteht da drauf dass die Gebiete die
ja offiziell oder aus seiner Sicht
annektiert hat dass sie ihm gehören und
dass die letztendlich abgegeben werden
müssen das ist von vorher schon etwas
interessant weil die Gebiete ja gar
nicht kontrolliert sondern er verliert
sie ständig weiter ist also in einer
sehr schlechten politischen Situation
wenn es zu einem Friedensschluss Thema
dann würde er zu Hause erklären müssen
was er gewonnen hat und das sehe nach
sehr sehr wenig aus seiner Sicht aus das
heißt für ihn ist ein schlechter Krieg
besser als ein schlechter Frieden
das war die Einschätzung des
Militärexperten Christian Mölling vielen
Dank für das Gespräch schöne Grüße nach
Mainz